welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and is Mobius an older version of
the teenage McDonald's employee named
Jack in Oklahoma in ly season 2 yeah
it's wober so we can indulge our sweet
tooth in a pretty crazy Theory the same
way Mobius treats himself to two helping
pie in lowkey episode 2 yeah the pie is
kind of part of all this didn't think we
would but we figured out the secret of
the pie this season as well as Mobius as
possible Orin that will account for Owen
Wilson's adorably distinguished nose his
Southern Roots his age and we're going
to talk about how many lakes are jet
skiable in Oklahoma okay this is a
theory that I pitched on Twitter early
Friday morning after Loki episode 2
dropped and I think this theory is just
so fun so I wanted to dive into it here
and we should all celebrate Mobius and
his love for pie with this Mobius shirt
that you can get as part of our Loki
collection at nerd rot. shop which is
really the best way to support us please
and thank you okay the little we know
about mob's life on the sacred timeline
was his lingering obsession with jet
skis he reads A wake magazine that in
season 1 episode 2 he tells Loki to stop
reading reading and later that episode
he begins to wax poetic about the idea
of jet skis in the early 1990s for a
brief Shining Moment there was a
beautiful Union of Form and Function
which we call the jet ski and a
reasonable man cannot differ you ever
been on one no no Mobius is love of jet
skis returns in season 2 episode 1 when
X5 dickish Le finds this magazine and
starts to taunt him for it jet skis seos
huh one of these calling your name obus
no I don't know about calling maybe
gently Whispering OB yes come take us
for a little spin you know the funny
thing about jet skis everyone thinks
that it's a personal watercraft and it's
actually a brand same way Kleenex is and
then in season 2 episode 2 X5 again gets
under mob' skin about his history on the
sacred timeline I mean who even are you
on the timeline do you
know doesn't matter I think it does does
matter because none of this is real W
okay the TVA is not your real home
Mobius isn't even your real name well
that's what I answer to do you have any
idea what kind of life you might have
left behind who might be waiting for you
back there I mean do you care and then
later Loki asks Mobius the same question
in the TVA automat over a slice of key
lime pie I mean don't you want to see
the life you're supposed to live before
they kidnapped you and brought you into
the TVA not really why because it's not
my life
but it could have been it isn't this is
I'd like to thank the guy who kidnapped
me and brought me here got me this pie
yeah this season is totally going to
explore Mobius is Past trailer footage
shows Loki time slipping into the
parking lot of a piranha Powersports
where you can see Mobius in the
background buying or selling a jet ski
first I thought he might have been a jet
ski salesman but I'm actually wondering
if he could be buying because the man
he's talking to is a teal vest that
matches the color of the store and
there's another woman with them so that
might might be a wife or a girlfriend
that Mobi has left behind the gentle
whisper that he referred to the real
reason he open hand slapped Brad even if
he wasn't aware why he was hitting him
and why he was so mad so how does Jack
the McDonald's employee in Brockton
Oklahoma in 1982 fit in with this well
Owen Wilson was born in 1968 so in 1982
he would have been 14 years old Owen and
his brothers were born in Dallas Texas
it's why they kind of have that folksy
southern accent though their voices have
evolved over time and to their own kind
of weird quirky sounding thing but Owen
Wilson is born and raised a southern boy
now Jack was introduced in the post-edit
scene of season 2 episode 1 as a
messy-haired blonde Southern boy with
blue eyes and a friendly demeanor well
you can try our new Chicken McNugget
saying we have a big
M and we kind of assume that Jack would
be a oneandone character from there but
no he returns in episode two first when
he tells Sylvia to refill the straws hey
um can you refill the straw disp when
you get a sick I've already done it now
you know notice in this moment Loki
enters by himself at first Mobius and X5
are not yet inside but by the time they
walk in Jack has turned so that his back
is facing them and Mobius would not have
seen his face and only then at this
point does Mobius say that he's going to
get an apple pie and he exits to the
side in the direction of the other
register at the counter now when I was a
kid family game nights were absolutely
dominated by Monopoly there's just
always been something nostalgic about
Monopoly for me which is why I now play
Monopoly go it's super easy to pick up
and play I normally do it while I'm
heating up lunch or something you can
actually accomplish a lot in Monopoly go
even if you're only playing for a few
minutes the game has a ton of new super
fun features like Ling on a railroad and
you can actually go on a bank heist to
steal money from your friends or
demolish one of their landmarks to steal
its value for yourself take the money
you get from destroying and Heist and
use it to build an Empire of your own in
major cities around the world like New
York and London build an Empire of your
own by clicking the link in the
description and downloading Monopoly Go
for free now it's also interesting to
note that Jack's line about refilling
straws comes right after we cut from
mobus in the parking lot on the left
side of frame to Jack on the left side
of the frame behind the counter and then
when we see Mobius in X5 later inside in
the background you can see Jack chatting
with another cashier and Jack is just
out of Mobius is ey line but he is right
behind him the two are kind of aligned
and it's likely that other cashier is
the employee who would have taken mob's
order not Jack regardless even if Mobius
saw Jack he barely remembers his past
life it's possible that he wouldn't
recognize his younger son up especially
if his younger self's appearance his
nose is slightly changed more on that in
a bit but there is an interesting moment
at the end of the episode when we cut
from Mobius on the left side of screen
in the Chron monitor Bay as Jack exits
the building on the left side of frame
so here he checks in on Sylvie do you
think you'll be in tomorrow
though yeah cool cool Jack mhm is your
mom on her way to pick you
up yeah uh she'll be here I'm
good
good night byebye so this series does
not really want us to forget about Jack
this is in the same episode where they
clearly want us to think about Mobius is
past and the fact that Mobius had a
different name and we learned how Mobius
loves pie and he loves McDonald's food
so yeah the 1982 timeline matches up the
region of America lines up yeah I think
Jack could be a young Mobius now you may
ask wait isn't Oklahoma landlocked uh my
friends you don't need to take a jet ski
on an open ocean or a great lake or a
Oklahoma has a ton of rivers in Lakes
you can totally buy and use a jet ski in
Oklahoma but either way Mobius told Loki
in season 1 episode 2 that he never even
rode a jet ski this was just a dream
that he always had a dream that you
could have from anywhere in America it's
just possible that this sweet sweet boy
from his teenage years grew up to
finally one day be able to buy a jet ski
but that was the moment he was pruned
heartbreaking that being his final
moment on the sacred timeline could be
why he still has jet skis on the brain
and remember in season 2 episode epode
two in the automat he said he would like
to thank the man who took him to the TVA
so that he could eat this pie I don't
know the context of this jet ski parking
lot shot in the trailer but it could be
that the TVA agent who recruits Mobius
could be Loki himself kind of like the
theory at the end of tenet that the
mystery member of the tenant
organization who recruited Robert
panton's character was a protagonist
played by John David Washington now you
may also ask was it the Brockton
McDonald's clearly marked on screen as
part of the branched timeline yes that's
true but that doesn't mean there wasn't
a McDonald's who existed in every
timeline including the sacred timeline
or any branches also by definition all
TBA employees were variants before they
came into the TVA variants come from
Branch timelines that get pruned so TVA
Mobius got extracted from some Branch
now there are probably exists some
variant of him on the sacred timeline
but that's not the one that got taken in
the TVA Jack is on a branch mobus came
from a branch since he's a variant so if
this theory is true would they address
Owen Wilson's unique nose so when Owen
Wilson was in high school in Dallas he
got in a fight and got punched in the
nose and then when he went to college at
University of Texas at Austin the nose
got injured again while playing some
football with friends this reminds me of
Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade when
they included a moment when River
Phoenix who was playing young Indie
accidentally Cuts himself on the chin
with a bull whip to justify the chin
scar that Harrison Ford as an actor has
always had this season of Loki could do
something similar where poor poor Jack
gets his nose injured in some silly way
like some altercation at McDonald's
Maybe defending Sylvie in a fight maybe
he's got a rough family I mean they
don't seem to be picking him up from
work there maybe 10 years from now our
man will climb aboard a jet ski in a
parking lot and fall on his face or
maybe he will injure himself on a
motorcycle and realize that there's a
watercraft equivalent of a motorcycle in
which Falls don't hurt you as bad hey
let me know your thoughts on this theory
in the comment below we've been down
this path before it it ends up not being
true it it's fine it's fine I just think
this is a fun Theory to think about
please support us with a looki or a
movia shirt from nerd riot. shop like
this one you can follow me at eaos
please subscribe to all three channels
in the new rockstars Network and we'll
see you next time bye-bye
everybody